l'année scolaire vient de commencer mais
savez vous combien d'enfants risquent de
ne pas manger à leur faim cette année on
est vite
[Musique]
au canada un million deux cent mille
enfants grandissent dans des familles à
faible revenu et ce sont tous les plus à
risque d'avoir faim par exemple on
estime que près du quart des élèves
entre 11 et 15 ans se rendre en classe
sans avoir déjeuné adéquatement le
canada c'est pas un bon élève c'est le
seul pays membre du g7 qui n'a pas de
programme national d'alimentation
scolaire sur 41 pays
le canada est au 37e rang pour éliminer
la faim chez les enfants il est derrière
des pays comme la slovaquie la hongrie
le chili et la roumanie sont mal
présentement en train de faire des
consultations pour mettre en place une
politique alimentaire au canada environ
une école sur quatre a un programme pour
nourrir les enfants
il ya des villes comme montréal qui met
les moyens pour qu'il y en ait plus si
les trois prochaines années dans toutes
les écoles de montréal
il va avoir des petits déjeuners au
québec on met des clubs des petits
déjeuners dans les écoles les plus
défavorisés ils ce sont les écoles qui
ont des codes puis 8 9 et 10 ça veut
dire qu'un enfant qui est issu d'un
milieu défavorisé mais qui est dans une
école côté de 1 à 7
il n'y a pas de chance d'avoir un club
comme celui-là si vous voulez qu'on
vérifie autre chose
écrivez nous
[Musique]